les stocks 3 et 4 les canes en gazon du
troisième reich
dès 1936 le général manstein proposa le
développement d'un véhicule blindé
chenilles et pour le soutien de
l'infanterie plus connu sous
l'appellation canon d'assaut en
allemange tourner des shoots diminutif
stung qui devint l'un des plus
importants véhicule blindé allemand de
la seconde guerre mondiale cinq
prototypes basée sur le châssis du
panzer 3,4 furent construits en 1937
avant que la firme halkett de berlin
entame la pleine production du modèle à
en janvier 1940 les versions suivantes
bea
bénéficiant de nombreuses améliorations
mais conservèrent globalement la même
apparence jusqu'à l'arrivée en septembre
1942 du mode à la fuite avec son canon
plus long et un design entièrement revu
seuls 24 canons dassault était en
service lors de l'invasion de la france
et des pays bas en mai 1940 affecté à
quatre batteries
leur efficacité dans le rôle d'engins de
soutien d'infanterie fut très élevé
il
je
en avril la chaume batterie 640 fut
affecté au régiment d'infanterie d'élite
grosse deutschland
rebaptisé 16e compagnie est engagé avec
le 10ème panzer korps de goût derian
bien que la doctrine officielle de 1940
voulu que les canons dassault ne soit
pas employer en combat anti char les
circonstances poussèrent les équipages à
s'en servir en tire direct contre les
chars démontrant au passage leur
capacité de tueur de chats qui allait
devenir bientôt une doctrine à part
entière un an après que les français se
soient rendus hitler envoya ses légions
contre l'union soviétique
la chaume artillerie s'était agrandie et
réorganiser les canons d'assaut ferait
partie en bataillon alignant chacun
trois batteries de 6 to
pour barbarossa les six bataillons
déployèrent approximativement 108 canon
d'assaut répartis entre les groupes nord
centre et sud
ils participèrent à de durs combats dès
le début de la campagne
bien que les canons d'assaut étaient
engagés dans le rôle premier de soutien
de l'infanterie les quantités de blindés
envoyés par l'armée rouge au devant des
colonnes allemandes pour contrer leur
avance vers veste amenèrent
inévitablement les bataillons de schluck
à être utilisé comme arme antichar même
s'il s'agissait seulement de protéger
l'infanterie à laquelle il avait été
affecté
ce qui ne leur pose a guère de problème
puisque les chars russes légers et
moyens souvent obsolètes et faiblement
blindés étaient facilement transpercée
par les obus des canons d'assaut
mais avec les nouveautés 34k vrais seins
et qu'avait 2 et leurs épais blindage il
n'en avait pas de même
les scoops trois rencontres est
exactement les mêmes problèmes que le
panzer 4 face à ces enjeux
ces deux concepts allemand était armé du
même canot l 24 de 75 mm à faible
vitesse initiale optimisé pour le tir de
bus explosif on a pu rapprocher
parmi les 44 bus transporté par le tube
plus de 80% à tête explosif
seul un faible nombre était performant
même lorsque les munitions perforantes
était utilisé
la faible vitesse à la sortie du canon
ne permettait pas toujours de produire
une énergie suffisante pour pénétrer les
épées blindage des nouveaux chars russes
enlevez tous les choux gras us here à
détruire ces nouveaux monstres
soviétique
en dépit de leur apparente limites
technologiques d'autres facteurs entrent
en ligne de compte au premier rang
desquels les compétences techniques des
équipages de stung l'entraînement leur
avait appris à combiner la mobilité du
chou young avec des tirs précis et
rapide permettant de toucher au but au
premier tir et d'exploiter à fond les
avantages de la machine telle que sa
silhouette basse et son blindage
frontale relativement épais même phase 1
et 34
l'addition de ces facteurs permettait
souvent à l'équipage du shooting de se
rapprocher à portée de tir et de
l'éliminer avant qu'il ait pu réagir
c'était particulièrement vrai dans les
premiers mois de la campagne alors que
de nombreux équipages russes ne vais pas
de procédure de commandement comparable
à celle des troupes allemandes
ce fut à l'été 1941 que les bataillons
de canon d'assaut commencèrent à décimer
les blindés russes annonçant 20000 char
détruit en 1944
les armées allemandes progressaient en
profondeur en russie et les bataillons
de canon dassault était constamment
engagé lorsque les panzer division
encerclaient les forces soviétiques dans
de grandes poches l'infanterie et
l'artillerie n'avait plus qu'à les
détruire l'artillerie d'assaut fut
fréquemment employé comme brigade
d'intervention les déployer d'un secteur
à l'autre
les forces soviétiques firent des
tentatives désespérées pour se dégager
vers l'est assez souvent cela permettait
des tirs à bout portant dans
l'infanterie soviétique prise en étau
devant les lignes la mort
la plus mémorable de ces batailles
appliquant la stratégie du chaudron fut
celle de kiev aussi 165 mille soldats
russes furent faits prisonniers par les
allemands après la bataille les forces
du groupe sud avancé vers l'est la
marche de la sixième armée de faune
reichenau vers kharkov visait à prendre
la 4ème ville d'union soviétique et l'un
de ses plus grands centres industriels
l' usine de tracteurs de kharkov était
par exemple l'une des plus grandes
unités de production de chars de l'union
soviétique à cette époque
les allemands prirent la ville à la mi
octobre la retirer lourdes pilonnaient
les défenses russe dans les faubourgs de
la ville tandis que l'infanterie se
frayait lentement un chemin pour les
prendre puis ils s'enfoncent air dans le
centre de kharkov les canons d'assaut
furent amenés pour tirer sur les
positions russes dans les bâtiments
autour du centre
protégé par les tirs de mitrailleuses
provenant des semis chemillé de
commandement le combat pour kharkov rude
et la vie ne tomba pas avant le 24
les livraisons en canon d'assaut de
remplacement furent envoyés à la gare
encore en service la plus proche du
front ces deux soupçons des modèles d
le 9 071 six porte encore son numéro de
châssis écrit à la craie avant son
départ de lusine halkett à berlin à la
fin du mois de septembre 1941 les
allemands lancèrent l'opération typhon
la dernière grande offensive pour
prendre moscou avant le début de l'hiver
les défenses soviétique aux portes de la
capitale furent brisés par les assauts
des panzers encerclant l'armée rouge au
cours des batailles jumelles de viazma
brillante
une fois encore les bataillons de canon
d'assaut à thuir l'infanterie pour tenir
la poche et empêcher les russes
désespéré d'en sortir quelques 663 mines
soviétiques furent faits prisonniers
mais moscou ne tomba pas l'arrivée des
grands froids et la contre offensive des
armées russes pris de court les
allemands mal préparés à affronter l'un
des pires hiver depuis 50 ans les
équipages de sung durent faire preuve
d'une grande rigueur pour empêcher
l'huile de moteur de geler la grèce des
mécanismes du canon de congeler et
maintenir leurs instruments de viser en
état bref maintenir à stung en état de
combattre relevait du miracle lorsque
les températures tombées à 30 degrés en
dessous de zéro
malgré tout les unités de canon d'assaut
continuer à infliger de lourds dommages
aux blindés russes comme en témoignent
les carcasses calcinées de cave et un
étaient 34 sur ces images
avec l'arrivée du printemps 1942 les
allemands avaient traversé la tempête et
voyait poindre la reprise des opérations
offensives censé conclure positivement
la guerre sur le front de l'est
en 1942 l'organisation des bataillons de
canon d'assaut fut à nouveau modifier le
nombre de shoots par batterie passant de
6 à 9
chaque batterie était alors composée de
trois sections de trois tombes avec une
force de 27 canada sous chacun ses
bataillons étaient bien plus puissant
qu'un an auparavant
d'autres changements furent réalisés
avec l'arrivée d'ashton de commandement
pour chaque batterie à la fin 1942
chaque bataillon alignait 30 canon
d'assaut hitler avait demandé à ce que
le blindage et l'armement du canada se
soit améliorée pour faire face aux
chartes et 34 et cavée mais le choc
modèle f n'apparut pas avant mars 1942
armée luca manca wk 42 75 mm plus long
il était initialement en 43 calibre puis
fut changée pour 1,48 calibre à les
premières images du choc 3f surprise
lors de la parade de rééquipement de la
première division ss life turns d'artaud
adolf hitler à paris le 29 juillet 1942
ici le salut du maréchal gerd von
rundstedt flanqué du nouveau commandant
des panzer ss paulao soeur et des
commandants de division le père gruppen
fureur ces petites riche mais notez les
couleurs des stocks de la life stand
d'achter ils sont en tain de sable
spécifiques au véhicule devant servir en
afrique du nord
suggérant que cela ait pu être la
destination originale de ces machines la
couleur standard des véhicules servant
en europe et sur les routes du front
russe ce moment était le gris foncé la
consigne ordonnant que tous les
véhicules adopte une base de couleur
sable ne fut pas donné avant février
1943 les premières images de ce tome 3
est faux combats furent tournées lorsque
le bataillon 203 marchait vers rostov
sur le don à la fin du mois de juillet
on aperçoit furtivement l'insigne du
bataillon un éléphant blanc sur la
superstructure de l'année stung
lorsqu'arriva le second hiver sur le
front de l'est les allemands étaient
bien mieux préparés équipée pour
affronter les froids extrêmes
une attention particulière fut portée
aux problèmes rencontrés par les panzers
et les canons d'assaut lors de l'hiver
précédent
la pression au sol dû à leur étroite
chenille est en forte
il leur était difficile de progresser
dans la neige profonde et il s'embourbe
est fréquemment la solution 20 sous la
forme d aux skateurs des raccords de
chenilles qui élargissait les chenilles
et réduisait la pression au sol ce qui
permettait une progression plus facile
dans la neige épaisse pour les panzers
ou ici pour les canons d'assaut lorsque
c'était possible comme sur ces images le
choc progressait sur route tout en
conservant les osc étonne pour se
positionner en sous bois où la neige
était plus profonde en cas de contact
avec l'ennemi la mobilité à porter par
les autres gayton permettait aux choux
guillot panzer de rétablir l'équilibré
lorsqu'il affrontait les chars
soviétiques doté de chenilles plus large
en décembre 1942
le dernier modèle de canon d'assaut
entrer en production bien que la caisse
reste à la même que sur le mode est la
fuite
la superstructure furent dessinés avec
une coupole pour le chef de bord et
l'ajout d'un bouclier pour assurer une
protection lors de l'utilisation de la
mitrailleuse de toit sur la trappe du
tireur l'économie de guerre allemande
connu une forte expansion et plus de
3000 choc fut refabriquée en 1943
l'arme blindés étaient dans une
situation désespérée mais la production
élevés et le faible coût des chouyoukh
fier de ce si l'alternative aux chars
dans les panzer division
pas étonnant alors que good eriane peu
après avoir été nommé directeur de
l'inspection générale des blindés et
tenté vainement de prendre le contrôle
des bataillons de canon dassault jusqu'à
l'heure affecté à l'artillerie pour les
incorporer dans les panzers plus de 600
canon d'assaut furent rassemblés pour
l'opération citadelle en juillet 1943
la plupart ferait partie en colonne de
canon d'as ou encore un autre changement
dans l'organisation
bien que le nombre de choc fut maintenu
à 31 la panzer grenadiers division
grosse deutschland déployait son
bataillon légèrement augmenté à 35 stung
tandis que les première deuxième et
troisième division de panzers s s
engageait chacune leur propre bataillon
ce fut la plus grande concentration de
canon dassault jamais mobilisés pour une
même opération
moscou qui était maintenant équipés de
shenzhen des jupes de blindage de 5 mm
attachés par des rails et couvrant les
flancs de l'engin elles furent
introduites en mars 1943 comme
protection balistique supplémentaire
contre les fusils antichar russe de 14,5
mm elle fonctionnait comme simple
blindage supplémentaires et elle était
conçu pour détourner les projectiles
lors de la bataille de koursk un les
canons dassault avait un camouflage à
trois tons avec une base de jaune sable
et un bariolage vert olive et marronne
de nombreuses roue de rechange étaient
transportés par les chtouki les panzers
pour cette opération les allemands est
en conscient que les soviétiques avaient
miné de larges zones
et qu'ils auraient à remplacer sur le
champ de bataille de nombreuses routes
endommagées par les mineurs
cependant les pertes dues aux mines
furent supérieur à ce que les allemands
avaient prévu les chefs de canon
d'assaut victorieux et est traité en
héros dans la presse allemande
voici le capitaine france commandant le
bataillon de choc de la division grosse
deutschland
après avoir reçu les feuilles de chêne
de sa croix de fer max venture était
capitaine dans life stand d'achter 1941
et commandait la 12e division le panzer
ss
mais le meilleur chef de chars de
l'artillerie dassault était sans doute
ou beaux prix musique qui devint le
premier sous-officier de l'armée
allemande à recevoir les feuilles de
chêne sur sa croix de fer pour ses
exploits à la veille de l'abandon par
hitler de l'opération citadelle l'armée
rouge lance à une série d'offensives le
long du front sud
juste avant l'opération youssef leur
offensive pour reprendre kharkov les
soviétiques lancé un raid majeur sur la
ligne us pour en extirper les allemands
les jetons 3f 8 visible sur cette
séquence appartiennent à la sixième
armée dans le secteur de milieux dessous
une bataille féroce fit rage évidemment
les allemands assailli par les russes
juste avant qu'ils ne lancent leurs
propres contre offensive en août pour
reprendre le terrain laissé aux
soviétiques depuis le 17 juillet les
deux prochaines séquences permettent de
voir les canons d'assaut dans le rôle
classique à ce stade de la guerre dans
la première séquence un grand nombre de
chocs 3g font mouvement transportant
l'infanterie roumaine à l'arrière de
leur plate forme pour attaquer une
colline tenus par les soviétiques
l'infanterie débarquer se déploie sous
la couverture des chu young qui tirent
des obus explosifs pour faire baisser la
tête à l'ennemi dans ce cas de figure
les soupçons dans le rôle pour lequel
ils ont été originalement conçu dans la
deuxième séquence nous pouvons voir les
canons d'assaut dans le rôle pour lequel
il allait être principalement utilisés à
savoir la destruction de charme
un groupe de chasse soviétique
s'approche des positions allemandes l'un
d'entre eux est un panthères capturés
qui est aussitôt détruit et dans
l'équipage russe est fait prisonnier
l'optique particulières utilisées par
les chefs de bord des choucas leur
permettent de tirer jusqu'à 2000 mètres
avec les obus perforant et jusqu'à 1500
m avec le but ap 40 plus léger la haute
vitesse initiale et la trajectoire très
rectiligne donné par de kananga wk 42 75
mm combiné aux optiques supérieur du
shooting permettent un bon taux de coups
au but au premier tir pour un équipage
entraîné l'armement principal de stung
était plus qu adéquat pour contrer les
t34 et leur canon de 76 à longue portée
comme on le voit ici lorsque la
reddition de l'italie fut annoncée le 8
septembre ickler décida d'un plan
d'urgence pour l'occupation de l'italie
de nombreuses unités militaires
traversèrent le col de brenner pour
entrer en italie notamment cette unité
de canon d'assaut les coûts qu'elle ait
joué un rôle important dans la défense
de la péninsule
le terrain italien est en nettement plus
favorable aux canons d'assaut et canons
automoteurs cauche a par conséquent les
allemands ne gardère qu'un nombre réduit
le panzer division sur le théâtre
italien
les canons dassault avait également joué
un rôle important en italie du sud lors
du débarquement allié à salernes le 9
septembre 1943
ils s'attendaient à une faible
résistance et penser rapidement sécurisé
naples le débarquement prix les
allemands par surprise mais leurs forces
dans la zone
la dixième armée du général von bychkov
était loin d'être négligeable
quoi qu'il en soit sonne la 7e prendre
leurs divisions doté de sent pançard de
36 canon d'assaut fut immédiatement
déployables pour contrer leurs assauts
elle fut envoyé au combat le 9 mai les
alliés étaient appuyés par de
l'artillerie navale des chars et un
appui aérien
à la fin de la journée la 16e panzer
division avait perdu la plus grande
partie de ses blindés la bataille de
salerne allaient s'intensifier jusqu'à
ce que les allemands choisissent de se
retirer pour limiter leurs pertes
ce tome 3 est fuite ici en italie
appartient la panzer division hermann
goering stationné à salernes depuis son
retour de tunisie et de sicile
six mois plus tard les canons d'assaut
modèle g de la panzer division hermann
goering prenez part à la bataille
d'alger où les batailles de la campagne
de monte cassino entre janvier et mai
1944 parmi lesquels le combat pour les
ruines de ce qui avait été un monastère
bénédictin mondialement connue furent
les plus compliquées de toute la
campagne européenne
la plupart du temps le sommet était tenu
par les parachutistes allemands qui
avaient même réussi à amener un canon
d'assaut avec eux pour fournir l'appui
nécessaire pour contrer les fréquentes
attaques des alliés la tactique du fuel
girls reflète l'emploi des canons
d'assaut durant toute la campagne
d'italie à l'affût dans les ruines d'une
maison bombardée le chaume
n'apparaissait que pour appuyer les
paras sur des contre attaques
ponctuelles dans l'incapacité de
profiter de sa mobilité à cause des
décombres ils nous aident ces chenilles
que pour orienter son canon vers
l'objectif
malgré tout les observateurs alliés
positionner dans les ruines pouvait
demander un tir d'artillerie très
rapidement ce qui obligeait le tonga se
retirer très vite après avoir fait feu
en attendant la demande d'appui suivante
pour les parachutistes de présence du
canon dassault a porté sans conteste une
aide précieuse dans la défense du sommet
en 1944 le canon dassault était l'un des
véhicules de combat blindés les plus
employés au sein de l'armée allemande
tout théâtre confondues dans cette
séquence les choux qui sont utilisés
comme artillerie dans une offensive de
contre guérilla en yougoslavie à
l'arrivée de l'hiver en russie
méridionale
l'armée allemande commence à battre en
retraite dans la nièvre
comme les autres unités de blindés
allemande
les détachements de canon d'assaut
continuer à opposer une farouche
résistance aux forces de l'armée rouge
bien que les pertes plus élevées à
koursk les effectifs en canon d'assaut
durant la période d'août jusqu'à
décembre continuèrent à connaître plus
de production que de pertes dans les
cinq mois précédents décembre la
production de stung fut 2810 machine
contre seulement 1060 engins perdu début
décembre 1943 le stock total de stung
présent sur tous les théâtres se montait
à 1880 canon d'assaut près de 400 de
plus que ceux disponibles au début du
mois de juillet et juste avant
l'opération citadelle
la réalité était qu'à cette période de
la guerre le scoop 3 était le blindé le
plus répandu au sein de l'armée
allemande à la fin 1943 un total de
trente et une brigade de canon d'assaut
étaient en activité la majorité sur le
front de l'est
de plus des détachements indépendant au
niveau corps d'armée étaient affectés
selon les besoins ainsi que des
bataillons organique dans certaines
unités de la waffen ss au début 1944 76
% de tous les canons d'assaut existants
opéraient sur le front de l'est
l'emploi croissant de l'artillerie
d'assaut en tant que chasseur de char
est clairement visible sur cette
séquence où un détachement de shoot du
groupement centre ont fait mouvement
pour contre attaquer un groupe de
blindés soviétiques en approche
l'action est rendue plus dramatique par
l'arrière plan un après midi d'hiver le
soleil commence déjà à s'évanouir une
fine couche de neige repose sur un sol
pierreux très dur ce qui permet au
groupe de progresser aisément avec leurs
chenilles
bien que semblant progresser au hasard
ces engins sont en réalité guidés par le
scoop de commandes
l'ennemi est engagée à distance le
terrain plat favorisant la ville
quoi qu'il en soit les chevaux ne tient
pas un mouvement ils s'arrêtent tirer un
certain nombre de cours puis changent de
position pour éviter la riposte de
l'ennemi
résultat de l'opération deux chars
détruits un thé 34 76 et un cave et 85
à la fin de l'été 1944 l'armée rouge
avait repoussé les forces allemandes à
la frontière hongroise
une équipe de propagande avait filmé ici
un détachement de choc en mouvement à
travers budapest pour monter au front
à l'arrêt les équipages de stung sont
entourés de jeunes admirateurs
appartenant aux organisations de
jeunesse fasciste hongroise
dans les combats qui s'ensuivirent dans
la plaine hongroise
les unités de canon d'assaut furent
intensément engagées contre les blindés
soviétiques ainsi qu'en appui de
l'infanterie dans des contre attaques
ponctuelles porté par des faucons
croisés et allemandes
lorsque le débarquement allié en
normandie fut lancée le 6 juin 1944
les autorités allemandes remarquera
stupéfiants sur son enthousiasme de la
part de la population
de nombreux allemands croyez sincèrement
que la seule issue possible était une
victoire allemande la clé des plans
allemands pour contrer le débarquement
allié résidait dans les formations
blindées fait atypique pour cette
période de guerre il y avait bien plus
de chats présents en france que de
canons d'assaut et de canons automoteurs
le nombre total de panzers déployables
en juin était de 1140 contre seulement 3
193 ch doug et autres engins automoteurs
bien que de brigade d'artillerie
d'assaut fut se stationner en france
de ceux rencontrés par les alliés
étaient en service au sein des
bataillons de chasseurs de chats des
panzer division des régiments de panzer
ss et des bataillons de stung rattachés
aux 1er et 2ème panzer ss sur ces images
et pour la première fois un exemplaire
du chou 4 un châssis de panzers 4 sur
lequel est monté une superstructure de
shock 3 en service au sein de la dix
septième division ss de panzers
grenadiers qui apparaît sur le champ de
bataille le 12 juin la production des
choux 4 1 démarrera en décembre 1943 et
seulement 11 cents exemplaires furent
construits une particularité notable sur
le show 4 et le chou 3 visible sur ces
images réside dans les autres comme vous
plein de le nouveau masque de canon en
forme de tête de cochon monté sur tous
les canons d'assaut à partir de février
1944 les traits durs combats dans les
étroits chemin bordé d'épaisses fait de
chaque côté étaient les pires conditions
opérationnelles pour les canons d'assaut
la place pour manoeuvrer était si
réduite qu'un engin à cannes en fixe et
est nettement désavantagée
ici le combat était souvent très
rapprochée de nombreuses coupures
victime d'un coup de bazooka -d
mais tous les canons d'assaut coups
d'archet roblin des alliés le sherman
étant tout aussi vulnérables aux obus de
75 mm que le thé 34
donc
en normandie le danger mortel pour les
canons d'assaut et passagers venait du
ciel
les requêtes des typhons britannique ne
trouvèrent pas plus de résistance dans
le blindage de stung que dans ceux des
panzers 4 panthère ou tigra les canons
dation ne pouvait rien faire d'autre que
rester à couvert en attendant que le
ciel se dégage et même dans ce cas là il
devait couvrir leurs superstructure de
feuillages permettant à leurs équipages
de se fondre rapidement dans le décor
par de la route en cas d'apparition des
jabots tant redouté les mouvements de
jours étaient extrêmement dangereux pour
les véhicules blindés allemands malgré
l'imposante ombrelle antiaérienne
fournis par l'adc a bien qu'un grand
nombre d'avions ali et était descendu la
puissance de feu des canons de 20 mm 37
mm et 88 mm de l'adc à ne fut jamais
suffisante pour entamer la supériorité
aérienne
dont jouissaient les alliés et
l'impuissance de la luftwaffe à
l'interdît
pour se protéger de nombreux équipages
plus tung creusait un trou et utilisent
à la masse de 23 tonnes de l'engin comme
boucliers en le positionnant au dessus
de la cavité
même au plus fort de l'action les
équipages des canons dassault qui se
distinguait au combat recevait la croix
de fer des mains de leur commandant en
chef
voici l'omr lieutenant franz ludwig qui
reçu la croix de chevalier en normandie
pour avoir détruit s'acharne britannique
en août la dureté des combats et le
sentiment que les choses ne se
déroulaient pas dans le bon sens pour
l'allemagne peuvent se lire sur les
traits fatigués des fantassins les
pertes aux allemandes en équipement
s'accroissait régulièrement sans
perspective de remplacement tandis que
les alliés semblaient disposer de
ressources matérielles inépuisable en
raison de la percée des américains dans
la péninsule du cotentin et de la
pousser les britanniques vers la poche
de falaise au sud les unités de canon
dachau survivante furent engagés dans de
violents combats les allemands tentaient
d' éviter l'encerclement du groupe ouest
sur ces images
un grand nombre de shoots 3 couvert de
ses mérites accompagné de canons
automoteurs marder trois sont parvenus à
supprimer un chasseur de chars
britannique achille
très peu de canon d'assaut et réussir à
survivre à la réduction de la poche de
falaise seul tome 4 est recouvert d'un
enduit anti mines sim rite sur toutes
ses surfaces verticales de même que ce
choc trois équipes et deux à homs
blender qui n'a plus de toit emporté par
une explosion
seul thomas oublie de ce car on donne
survécu que pour être abandonné par son
équipage avant que les ponts ne
s'effondre
il y a un énorme trou dans la couverture
médiatique des combats du front de l'est
et qui équivaut à la période de
l'offensive russe pendant l'été 1944
la destruction du groupe centre et la
perte d'un demi million de soldats tués
ou faits prisonniers puis la plus grande
défaite des forces allemandes
lorsque les journaux recommencèrent à
couvrir les combats du front de l'est
les unités allemandes comme ce
détachement de stocks opérées sur les
frontières polonaise
les images d'unité d'artillerie d'assaut
en action sur le front de l'est entre
l'automne 1944 et la fin de la guerre
sont plus courantes que celle des chats
pour mon la même période
dans presque tous les cas les unités de
stung sont montrés dans le rôle de tueur
de chats opérant conjointement avec mes
canons antichars et des canons de décès
à 2 88 mm pour engager les blindés
russes
sans déduire les lourdes pertes subies
pendant l'été 1944 la production de
tubes 3 et 4 à tennie près de 5000
unités
les stocks de canon d'assaut étaient
supérieures de deux mille engins comparé
au même mois de l'année précédente
une brigade d'artillerie l'assaut et
autres unités de stung était toujours
extrêmement efficace et coûter cher aux
blindés soviétiques
la destruction de 20000 charus parler
stung était décompté alami 1944 à la fin
de la guerre 10 mille de plus venaient
s'ajouter à ce bilan il ne fait aucun
doute que l'armée où je regardais ses
unités avec un certain respect le 1er
août 1944 le général port komorowski
commandant l'armée intérieure polonaise
donna l'ordre du soulèvement de varsovie
en quatre jours les polonais avaient
repris les quatre cinquièmes de la ville
leur espoir d'être relevé par les russes
si va nourrir lorsque les hameaux
rappelèrent leur unité de tête leur
donnant ainsi la marge de manoeuvre dont
elle avait besoin pour écraser
l'insurrection
la punition des allemands fut féroce les
unités lechuga fournissant l'appui feu
pour nettoyer la ville et en finir avec
le soulèvement
au début de septembre 1944
l'offensive soviétique connu une pause
permettant aux allemands de créer un
semblant de front fixe en pologne
orientale et dans l'est de la prusse les
pertes allemandes en hommes et en
matériel habite été colossal
tandis que les médias donnent l
impression d'un flot régulier et continu
de fourniture matériel de l'arrière vers
le front il ne parlait pas de la
détérioration des conditions de
ravitaillement en carburant ceux qui
avaient un impact significatif sur les
capacités opérationnelles et la mobilité
des allemands ceci en dépit du haut
niveau de production des usines
d'armement en allemagne
sous le tir de barrage par des canons
automoteurs vesper un détachement de
canon dassault fait mouvement contre les
positions soviétique en lituanie au
moins un des canons d'assaut vue sur ces
images est un modèle g avec le ca ou
coop blender et une épaisse couche de
béton appliquée sur la bande de la
superstructure
les autres tongs sont des anciens
modèles et tous ont une couche de zim
rite appliqué ici ou là
ces contre attaques locales furent
filmés jusqu'à la fin de la guerre celle
ci se termine avec le sourire de soldats
qui n'auront plus d'impact sur la
situation stratégique et le déclin
militaire de l'allemagne
contrairement à l'ouest un l'ampleur des
opérations sur le front de l'est ne
permit pas à l'armée de l'air soviétique
d'atteindre le même degré de supériorité
aérienne les forces mobiles allemande
était capable de se déplacer avec un
niveau de liberté d' attaque bien
supérieur à celui du front ouest
constatable par le peu de feuillages
présent sur les véhicules allemands dans
de telles conditions la luftwaffe
pouvait fournir un appui au sol l'un des
appareils les plus efficaces et te lunch
lhs 129 b opérant en vagues de quatre
appareils les hs 129 étaient armés de
deux mitrailleuses et deux canons de 20
mm et emporter de l'armement
supplémentaire pour attaquer les blindés
russes
l'ultime version du hs 129 dans le rôle
de tueur de chars volant mettait le
modèle b3 qui entrait en service à la
fin 1944 début 1945 et qui était armé
d'un canon de 75 mm sous son fuselage
lee
la chasse aux chars n'étaient pas
toujours synonyme d'engagement à longue
distance dans ce cas les shoots 3 servi
par des parachutistes avancer vers des
positions soviétique connu en
transportant des petits groupes devant
tassin équipés pour le combat rapproché
avec les chars leurs armes étaient les
incroyables comme à fos à usage unique
et les panzers shrek 2 88 mm
et
les canons d'assaut sont ici en
embuscade près du bois duquel émergent
les chars soviétiques
le premier est teinté 34,76 rapidement
détruit par un shu
second t34 est éliminé par un soldat
servant un pont d'or serait qu on peut
noter à l'arrière de cette harnes la
considérable flamme de départ qui oblige
son opérateur évacuer immédiatement la
position après le tir la puissance de la
munition de 88 mm est tel qu'il était
capable de perforer le blindage de
n'importe quel char soviétique ou alliés
y compris le yes 2 le chat rue
s'enflamme est teinté 34,85 qui ici a
été détruit par les stung plutôt que par
les armes d'infanterie
ce détachement de chou coopérant en
prusse orientale à l'automne 1944
craignant une attaque aérienne
soviétique a pris la peine de camoufler
ces engins avec du feuillage l'opération
semble se limiter à la reprise d'un
village tombée aux mains des soviétiques
de nombreuses coques sont des modèles
tardif avec le masque du canon en est le
cochon est légal est de retour en acier
tous ont néanmoins tapissé du filet de
camouflage que les équipages de secours
transporte à l'arrière de leur véhicule
est fixé par les pièces de métal
improvisé conçu et soudée sur le terrain
ce manque apparent d'activité ennemies
donne l'impression d'une reconstitution
au profit des équipes de propagande
les allemands n'étaient pas plus
réfractaires que les alliés à ce type de
méthode
lorsqu'il fallait filmer car les uns
comme les autres poursuivait le même
objectif
l'infanterie allemande fait mouvement
pour attaquer les positions soviétique
sous un tir de barrage des canons
antichars de 88 mm pack 43 utilisé comme
artillerie les images de ce toubib en
actions sont assez rares dans cette
séquence
un détachement de choc 4 est en train de
contre attaquer les troupes soviétiques
en hongrie fin 1944
le concept du chou quatre et issu d'une
demande d'hitler concernant la
production des canons dassault qui fut
stoppé lorsque lusine halkett de berlin
fut bombardée par les alliés en décembre
1943 elle précisait que la
superstructure du shock 3 soit adaptée
au châssis du panzer 4 le chou 4 fut
livrée aux unités d'artillerie d'assaut
de la même manière que le choc 3 et fut
utilisé selon les mêmes tactiques m
hitler autun d'imposantes forces
blindées en hongrie pour barrer la route
à l'avance des soviétiques
même au détriment de ses troupes en
pologne de nombreuses unités de shogi
furent engagés et des images de ces
opérations nous permettent de voir de
nombreuses caractéristiques des derniers
modèles j'ai sorti des usines à partir
de mars avril 1944 mandin de quelques
shoots 3 occasionnellement vu avec du
béton ajouté au glacier à 20 la plus
grande modification réside dans l'ajout
d'une mitrailleuses télécommandées sur
le toit du véhicule à la place du
bouclier utilisé avec la mg 34 ou mg 42
cela permettait aux mitrailleur de
servir son arme qui était alors fixée en
permanence au toit du ch look sans
s'exposer
bien que cette modification fut plus
souvent réalisés sur des chocs 3 et des
choux 4 à masquer de canaux en est de
cochon on voit aussi sur ces images un
stock 3 avec l'ancien masque
à cette période les unités de stung
devait affronter deux plus puissants
blindés soviétiques que le thé 34 le têt
34 équipé d'un nouveau canon de 85 mm et
est le plus fréquemment rencontrées sur
le champ de bataille
de même que le i s de staline lourdement
blindés ce dernier poser des problèmes
aux canons d'assaut des tactiques furent
donc mise au point pour permettre aux
engins allemand de vaincre ce chat russe
très puissant
lors des deux premières semaines
d'octobre 1944 le premier front de la
baltique soviétique par 20 jusqu'à la
côte de la mer baltique isolant ainsi
les restes du groupe d'armées nord dans
la péninsule de courlande hitler refusé
d'évacuer la position par la mer croyant
que les 26 division allemande bloqués
ici allez jouer un rôle important en
attirant des troupes soviétiques qui
manqueraient ailleurs il permis une
évacuation limitée d'un million cinq
cent mille soldats et civils allemands
furent évacués de courlande de prusse et
de poméranie entre janvier et mai 1945
ou derian qui était à ce moment là le
chef de l'état major général voyage
isolement d'autant de troupes comme une
folie stratégique alors que leur
présence serait qu'être si précieuse
pour renforcer les forces allemandes en
pologne orientale et par la suite sur
l'oder en 1945
les allemands avaient de la chance que
la flotte de la baltique soviétique soit
inopérante et que la kriegsmarine plus
capable de maintenir le contrôle des
eaux au large de courlande et de la
prusse orientale
de nombreux soldats pu s'échapper de
courlande
et beaucoup furent tués dans les féroces
combats qui se déroulèrent lorsque
l'armée rouge repris son avancée vers
l'ouest en janvier 1945
en dépit de son isolement
les images des combats de courlande
parvint tout de même jusqu'en allemagne
même si les russes lancèrent un grand
nombre d' attaques contre les positions
tenues par les allemands il ne pensait
pas que celle ci représentait une menace
sérieuse
coupé du monde comme ils l'étaient les
allemands du cours landon devait
repousser les troupes soviétiques hors
de leur périmètre défensif avec des
moyens de plus en plus faible les unités
étaient dispersés les contre attaques
contre les positions russes tels que
celles vues sur ces images
menés par un petit détachement de ce top
3 et d'infanterie était au mieux des
ripostes les ressources n'étaient pas
disponibles pour en faire autre chose
que des contre attaques ponctuelles
s'efforce continué à décliner jusqu'à la
fin de la guerre la reddition des
troupes allemandes survivante sur 90 en
mai 1945
il
à la fin octobre 1944 de violents
combats eurent lieu sur les frontières
occidentales de l'allemagne les canons
d'assaut transportant des fantassins
sont ici en train de contre attaquer les
forces de la 3e armée américaine en
sarre
l'épais camouflage et le feuillage de
ces engins témoignent de la crainte et
du respect inspiré aux équipages par les
redoutables jamais
les stocks du notaire avec les panthères
et lorsqu'ils ouvrent le feu sur les
forces américaines
ils le font la plupart du temps depuis
les couverts des sous bois dans de
telles conditions les panthères comme
les choux qui peuvent tirer parti de
leur canot à l'eau
supérieurs à ceux des chamans américain
brandon inge
un observateur d'artillerie cible des
positions américaines et les canons de
105 mm ouvrent le feu
il en est
sous un tir de barrage et sous le
couvert de fumigènes l'infanterie
progresse vers les positions américaines
équipées d'une large gamme d'armement
dont le lance-roquettes anti-char
panzerfaust
me transmet sofia
les sherman et astrac semble avoir été
broyés par les canaux à longue portée
des canons d'assaut et les panthères au
moins deux dm4 ont été victimes
d'incendiés interne dont l'intensité a
fait brûler la peinture et réduit le
caoutchouc des roues ensemble
malgré un rationnement impitoyable de
ses ressources
hitler fut capable de trouver 1200
panzer et canon d'assaut pour les 5e et
6e panzer armée ss qui seront le fer de
lance de l'opération brume d'automne son
offensive ratés dans les ardennes
lorsqu'elle fut lancée le 16 décembre
les alliés furent totalement pris par
surprise
les allemands progressaient rapidement
sa sauce unités de la première armée
la percée la plus à l'ouest fut celle
des unités de la 5ème panther armée de
monteux feu le vin elle se battait pour
dinan et le franchissement de la meuse
pour avancer sur bastogne qui ne peut
être prise ceux-ci eu un impact majeur
sur la percée allemande qui s'arrêtent 1
le 23 le 26 la 3e armée américaine
contre attaque a depuis le sud pour
renforcer bastogne les nuages bas qui
avaient cloué au sol l'aviation alliée
pendant près de 10 jours se dispersèrent
les avions britanniques et américains
lancèrent alors des attaques percutantes
sur les colonnes allemandes sans
protection avec pour conséquence la
destruction de nombreux chars et canon
d'assaut à la mi janvier les forces
allemandes survivante battaient en
retraite jusqu'à leur point de départ en
ayant perdu quelques 600 panzer heschung
une seconde offensive allemande baptisée
opération north bild fut lancée en
alsace le 31 décembre 1944
l'objectif était de piéger cette
division de la sixième armée américaine
et de reprendre strasbourg
contrairement à ce qui s'était passé
dans les ardennes le renseignement allié
fut en mesure de prévenir le
commandement américain d'une attaque
allemande imminente des unités de canon
d'assaut furent impliqués dans des
combats violents et acharnée mais trois
jours après le début de leur ville tête
l'offensive s'arrêta les pertes
allemandes s'élevait à 25 mille hommes
sans compter les panzers riche tout
détruit pour les forces allemandes en
pologne orientale l'offensive russe
lancé depuis la tête de pont de bras 9
fut un coup de tonnerre
un correspondant de guerre allemand
rapporta que les soviétiques avaient
engagé des masses d'hommes d'armes et de
matériel dans ce combat hivernale entre
les carpates et même elle à une échelle
encore jamais atteinte en cinq ans de
guerre d'innombrables division
d'infanterie et unités blindées arrivait
depuis la vistule comme l'avait prédit
coup derian les positions allemandes en
pologne s'effondrèrent comme un château
de cartes et à la mi février les russes
avaient atteint les ript lauder
les pertes en canon d'assaut en janvier
sur les deux fronts s'élevait à 323
machine de 110 exemplaires avaient
quitté les chaînes d'assemblage en
février en dépit des bombardements
alliés
les rapports indiquaient que le stock
total de chf 3 et 2 t4 atteignent 1 3610
engins ce qui en faisait le blindé ayant
le plus grand nombre d'unités en service
la situation désespérée en ressources
humaines allemande dans la seconde
moitié de 1944 pousse à la proclamation
en octobre de la mobilisation de tous
les hommes de 16 à 60 ans au sein du fox
tombe la milice populaire
dans quelques-unes des dernières images
de la guerre tourné par les équipes de
propagande de nombreux funk tome marche
dans les rues de bresse là haut
l'une des villes sur l'honneur désigné
par hitler comme forteresse est prise
avant qu'il soit encerclé le 14 février
livraison d'armes inclut à de nombreux
goliath un véhicule de démolition
télécommandé qui fut dévoilée au flunch
tourner juste avant leur déploiement
contre les troupes soviétiques en
approche habillée de manière à se
confondre avec leurs ennemis
ces civils mal entraînés en uniforme
mais d'une valeur militaire incertaine
furent envoyés au combat contre la
déferlante des forces soviétiques
conjointement à l'arrivée de ce flux mme
var les renforts en matériel de l'armée
régulière à bord des trains venant de
l'ouest 1 il est possible d'identifier
parmi les cas non bâchés et les
automitrailleuses un unique king tiger
et un certain nombre de tiac panzer 4,70
les canons d'assaut appartenant à une
peine leur division ss arrivent avec
leur véhicule d'appui notamment les
dernières versions du semis chemillé
blindés modèle 251 ou sdk fbn 251 des
troupes ss débarquer des camions se sont
équipés de panzers faust et de panzers
shrek
d'ailleurs leurs armes personnelles sont
issues d'une large gamme de modèles et
de générations il s'avance dans la
bataille et sont rejoints par un
détachement de canon d'assaut dans nos
combats qui suit les schtroumpfs sont
couverts par les tirs d'artillerie
moyenne est lourde tandis qu'ils
avancent pour repousser une attaque de
blindés soviétiques en approche le long
de la voie ferrée
après avoir ajusté leurs visées sur les
blindés ennemis les jetons ouvrent le
feu un certain nombre de coups touchent
leur cible
une équipe mg 42 couvre la progression
de l'infanterie alors que celle-ci
s'avance pour examiner les restes d'un
char soviétique deux t4 85 sont éventrés
par les obus de 75 mm des canons
d'assaut tandis que plus loin le long de
la voie se trouvent les carcasses de
deux m4a de sherman provenant du prêt
bail consenti par les américains la taxe
se poursuit alors que les stocks sont
rejoints par plusieurs panthères dans ce
film le dernier jamais réalisée sur les
canons d'assaut en action nous pouvons
voir ces machines engagées dans le rôle
qui était devenu progressivement le leur
celui du chasseur de charles quint que
la notion de véhicules blindés
s'entourait les pu être contestée par
quelques sceptiques
un bilan de plus de 30000 chars
soviétiques détruits au combat sur une
durée de 4 1 on laisse à penser que ce
concept de canon d'assaut et pu être
tout sauf un échec
on
on ne peut pas
non
débat
perdu
la panique pas
mon jeu
un comptable
arrêt
on
non
le
ne pas
il
on
il fait
12 ans
non
bravo
n'est ce pas
on
allez
il
non
on
demont